[Music]
and I drop murder news our job makes you
diarrhea I'm here to tell you something
about that after all I'm ready but it's
just salt and water no there's this one
particular chemical in it that causes
diarrhea even to the point where you can
oh [ __ ] I told you get a bottle of isay
and you go I saw that in a movie yeah
Dumb and Dumber mission impossible
wedding crashers wedding crashers drink
in highschool 9th grade remember this
there's this [ __ ] named Sarah she's
been my bully my whole life what's up
there good now Oh cuz you take karate
lessons and [ __ ] her up yeah and she put
Visine and my water during lunch when I
stood up to go somewhere and nobody told
me all my friends are sitting yeah I
thought not like a month later but like
there's nothing happened
oh I don't even remember that day how
did you find out later one of the people
told me that was sitting with me oh you
didn't have you didn't throw up and have
diarrhea
oh maybe Sharon but or not because like
I was chillin yeah lucky enough yeah I'm
Sarah what [ __ ] that's chemical warfare
baby yeah I would want to slit her
throat afterwards oh I'm not a bleachers
bury the body that hurts my feelings
yeah I never had people like that around
me all right submitted by Tyco as one oh
yeah all right a woman who goes by no we
really because I told a bi and he goes
like this step a little bit either this
just depends on you guys
a women poisoned her husband with
eyedrops has been arrested for murder
can you put that much to poison someone
shot himself to death anticipating that
breath cuz every time but it sound like
I get the breath out you guys are
already talking over me so I'm like
okay it worked alright so this woman her
name is Lana she poisoned oh she
actually she confessed to poisoning her
husband by spiking his food and water
for three days with eyedrops Wow boo -
she was squirting that Shauna's burgers
and this fool is like they're hella well
off like they'll own this huge man yeah
and then if I kill GI get hella money
yeah life insurance aren't you oh we
have my free shirts for each other and
for Tyler and ourselves anything bad
happens like this I don't got no I just
got health insurance why is life
insurance isn't worth it to you cuz yeah
you know nothing's happening yeah yeah
yeah mainly wouldn't you have kids yeah
if Jill kills me too so it really
depends on who kills who first we should
kills me she gets my fantastic in the
clause in the contract that's the
prerequisite of being rich like you have
to expect that one day you're gonna kill
your spouse well I'm not rich yeah so no
you but you're gonna be those so you
gotta just gotta get ready for it
awesome he's already planning so you got
a good job yeah yeah so two years prior
to this man dying she accidentally shot
him with a crossbow
what the [ __ ] yeah that's sick what was
he doing it using the [ __ ] losing the
flower bowl I picture like this
in the bedroom I picture this scene from
10 Things I Hate About You there's
nothing wrong with having a crossbow
okay I want one can you get me yeah I'm
by one right after Thanks
I swear - I'm not messing around so she
shot up more dishes shoot him I'm not
sure she shot him though he survived the
crossbow funny he's just like all these
things are happening to me and I don't
know why but he died with the eyedrops
yes she must really hate this dude it
was ruled an accident back in 2016 he
said that he's like no I don't believe
in the head but he's like no my wife
wasn't trying to kill me because she
shot up in the head in the bedroom in
the middle of the night she woke up and
accidentally shot I was just playing
with my crossbow in the middle than that
you know how I do they had that kind of
relationship though where they always
goof around baby I just picture the
[ __ ] arrogance she was trying to load
the crossbow and that she was Larry any
morning tonight it was my back early in
the morning I don't know exactly what
time that's a break a dog yeah like she
was having difficulty with it and I so
she went upstairs to have her husband
help her she was sleeping and that's the
man accidentally [ __ ] I just know
what reason she gave the court like why
was she was doing that at 5:00 in the
morning what she got out yes
no I love my yeah would you guys believe
like I don't know would not believe my
fiance not even a little bit no [ __ ]
that I believe just yeah right because I
have weapons all over the house and like
yeah but then I'd give her a wink from
the cross really oh okay cop you'd be
missed but I
yeah well the husband was saying that
his wife suffers from sleepwalks like
sleep kill like she that's amazing yeah
but then she was telling the cops back
then that her husband is mentally
abusive and has mood swings and it
changed in a moment from nice to cool
but that he had never hit her so her
feelings I feel like both of these
[ __ ] are crazy
yeah and it's a war zone in that
household do you anymore now he's dead
yeah one person won the war I'm actually
more interested in what his house looks
like yeah yeah I kind of feel like a
game of Thrones and Steven from South
Carolina
he looks at to you like that's like what
a stereotypical like Beverly Hills daddy
looks like oh yeah look at him Jesus
Christ why does he look like [ __ ]
Wayne Newton or mr. Las Vegas no I can't
tell if that fools Asian or not yeah I'm
sorry are APRI that crazy white mana I
mean she doesn't seem seem like she
sleeps much you know I mean or what when
your bags look like [ __ ] Gucci I
bagged her bags has bags her I know dude
that shit's like to coin purses sagging
like a [ __ ] so she going to
trial for murder
yeah how did so what happened when did
she confess what happened was she gave
him all that she's like I wasn't trying
to kill him I just wanted him to die
real what can happen they're saying is I
can cause severe seizures stop your
breathing and leave you in a coma yeah
and then also like all those stomach
problems you throw I rather die than to
be in a coma because I have a theory
that when you're in the coma place then
you're kind of like trapped in Inception
world and you're you there's no escape
and [ __ ] and it's just like you're
trapped in a dream nightmare
like what if you just don't know that
to you you are dead and that's that's
just death wait we do we go yeah oh man
that means you just active you got a
surprise that can chance you can just
accept it that's the cool part okay no
let's say you're in a hospital right now
they said we're gonna give you surgery
you might wake up in a coma would you
sign do not resuscitate within like 30
days or would you be like leave me on my
support till I wake up all right like
what's the time limit here Oh me and
download my brain in my next body and
wake me to [ __ ] up the idea I think I
went write down whatever she's
comfortable with she's gonna be the one
taking care of me so much that's a wake
up for another two minutes please come
to terms I'm moving on she's only been
out for five minutes no no it's okay I
don't want it I don't want to cry he
gets dental work and [ __ ] pull the plug
it's local anesthesia huh actually um I
was with a friend when his mom was on
life support and then they pulled the
plug you know were there to support him
I was really sad we pulled the plug on
my grandpa he wanted to he was like I
don't wanna be [ __ ] stuck to these
machines all day because if I ever like
going to call me just Paulette uh he was
kind of I think it was gone for like
like mentally garbage so biologically
living a full eye thing with two days if
there's a chance to survive [ __ ] yeah
but I don't want to like 5% but Sears
yeah I don't want to come back and then
still be trapped like you know how some
people they they go through like severe
strokes and they can't speak anymore so
you know everything that's going on but
you can't communicate and all you could
do is read know they have ways of
communicating yeah like thank you they
follow your eyes and you could spell
things and if I could be like Stephen
Hawking and be like then I'll [ __ ] do
it all day I'll just type with two
fingers [ __ ] you [ __ ] you fu fu ever
yeah I feel like if I was in that state
just give me [ __ ] hella drugs and now
we can make a video of a vegetable
that's highest ecstasy so I have a
[ __ ] boner in my scrubs or not my
screw my gown experiment on me so that
the world to have the pleasure of
knowing what this looks like why don't
we just donate your organs
look who's Beth boring like people
people Renault what a stomach looks like
but imagine a dead dog that dances
walking electrocuted right we don't know
what that looks like so I'd be down yeah
that's like a zombie dance yeah Pam
that's very next level so if I'm a
vegetable
give me some crazy crack some viagra and
then electrocute me when you watch and
watch what happens to me and then the
world can go oh so that's what happens
when you mix these three together [ __ ]
with my past life as we film more your
just your faith in your relationship he
like uncovers something that I didn't
know about him and it he has to choose
this time would tell everyone these
things I'm not thinking of these things
when I'm watching Ben Shephard [ __ ]
thing I was just like you never asked me
what's the weirdest porno you ever
watched it's golden retriever with these
questions
I don't know cuz we're all the same
[ __ ] they don't know you know what
here thirteen there's only like there's
there's only a few videos that are going
viral if there's there's like how much
other my [ __ ] or there's that
like only a few things that are going
viral yes and I was wonderful there's
actually a girl on YouTube that that
claims she [ __ ] her dog and it's like
pretty awesome it was awesome that
wasn't her and but she was saying that
it's pretty good like you should be
closer to your dog and like watch that's
[ __ ] crazy
[Music]
[Music]